When using Path Tracer, post-processed material buffers exist to let artists and TDs access
and manipulate the raw render data generated by Path Tracer after it's computed lighting,
shading, and ray interactions, but before tone mapping and final composition.
Selecting from the Path Tracing Buffer Texture node's dropdown settings, we have a few options
for changing the buffer texture.
This displays the full Path Trace lighting results, including all light interactions.
Denoise Radiance shows the lighting results after the denoise smooths out noise.
Albedo displays the pure material color, independent of light or shadow.
Normal shows the surface direction information that affects shading and denoising.
And finally, Variance highlights where the Path Tracer's noise or sampling instability
is at its highest.
In the next section, we're going to talk about reducing artifacts.